hello again and welcome to up all night
I'm a knight I'm a horse neigh
last week on the show we covered a bunch
of great ways to prank news today I'm
gonna do the same thing all over again
because I have no imagination it's
opposite day
we begin today with a PC trick we're
gonna remap the Internet Explorer icon
first I need to find myself a screen
saver so I'm gonna go down to the Start
menu and go to search all files and
folders I'm gonna search asterisk dot
SCR and your screen savers will show up
a really quick and easy way to get the
target destination for these screen
savers is to right-click on them and
send them to the desktop as a shortcut
now that I've got a shortcut for the
screen saver on my desktop I can right
click on the icon choose properties and
then copy the target destination once
I've got that on my clipboard I'm going
to go up to my internet explorer icon
right-click properties and paste in the
screen saver target destination now
anytime someone comes to this computer
to open up Internet Explorer they get
the screen saver they can always move
the mouse to cancel the screen saver but
when they try to open Internet Explorer
again boom screen saver screen saver
over and over and over again if you want
to be really silly you can change the
target destination to this code which
you'll find in the description when
double clicked an icon with this
destination will actually restart the
entire computer Oh No
my saddle is my clothes we're all fans
of the slow minimized but did you know
that you can use terminal to freeze the
slow minimize while it's happening all
you have to do is open up terminal
applications utilities terminal type in
kill all space doc do ck with a capital
D but don't press ENTER now go to any
type of window that you want to mess up
and hold down shift then click minimize
you'll get a weird wavy pattern go back
to terminal quickly and press ENTER and
boom the window is frozen in a weird
shape but can still be used it's
completely functional that's more cool
than a bag of oats and of course to
return it to its normal shape all you
have
minimize the window and bring it back up
again
copy the JavaScript in this video's
description and paste it into your
browser's address bar press Enter and
all of a sudden every image on the
screen will break free and spin around
like crazy oh pretty
you
I'm gonna be glue someday